There's lots of ways to be as a person,...
...and some people express their deep appreciation in different ways.
But one of the ways that I believe people express their appreciation to the rest of humanity...
...is to make something wonderful and put it out there.
And you never meet the people, you never shake their hands,...
...you never hear their story or tell yours.
But somehow, in the act of making something with a great deal of care and love,...
...something's transmitted there.
And it's a way of expressing to the rest of our species our deep appreciation.
So, we need to be true to who we are.
And remember what's really important to us.
That's what's going to keep Apple, Apple:...
...is if we keep us, us.